These days, it’s not enough to take a film
at face value.
Viewers are always analyzing each scene for
a deeper meaning or subtext, trying to uncover
any hidden messages the filmmakers may have
been planting.
Sometimes it’s just for fun, a product of
having watched a movie several times over.
Then there are the cases where fans might
be on to something, letting others see the
final product in a new light.
We’ll let you be the judge for our next
list: 10 amazing movie theories that totally
change everything.
The Hobbit trilogy
After the highs of the Lord of the Rings films,
the Hobbit trilogy was a bit of a disappointment.
The plot of one book was stretched over the
course of three long films, which were all
over-reliant on CGI.
There could be a good reason for that.
One theory suggests that what we’re seeing
on the screen is Bilbo’s “reimagining”
of his adventures as he writes his book, spicing
everything up so they’re more extravagant.
It wouldn’t be out of the ordinary for Bilbo
to get a little fantastical as he tells his
story.
It sounds nice, but it’s probably Peter
Jackson’s fault for going into the project
without a final plan.
The Dark Knight
Heath Ledger’s Joker is given no backstory
in this comic book sequel, so fans had to
devise one on their own.
A popular belief is that the Joker is a veteran
of the Iraq War and suffers from PTSD.
This would explain his intricate knowledge
of weapons and ability to conceive one master
plan after another to terrorize Gotham.
He also mentions that people don’t think
twice about a “truck load of soldiers”
blowing up, almost in a disdainful manner.
If the Joker served in the military, that
line receives a whole new context and is arguably
sympathetic.
We’ll never know the truth behind Nolan’s
Joker, but this is as good a guess as any.
The Prestige
Christopher Nolan’s tale of magicians is
full of twists and turns as it is.
What about one more?
The main trick in the film is the Transported
Man, which Borden achieves with a twin, while
Angier uses a machine that clones – and
drowns - himself on a nightly basis – or
so it would seem.
One theory proposes that Angier always used
a double and didn’t introduce the drowning
aspect until the final night, when he knew
Borden would investigate behind the stage,
framing his rival for murder.
Earlier scenes in the film seem to work against
this, but it would be a crazy revelation if
it turned out to be true.
Inception
By now, most people are familiar with the
theory that Cobb’s wedding ring is his real
totem, but there’s another hypothesis about
this master thief.
While is accomplices refuse to tell anyone
about their totems out of fear for the consequences,
Cobb openly discusses how his spinning top
works with others, suggesting that he intentionally
is leaving himself open for a dream attack.
Cobb is slowly but surely losing his grip
on reality and could be becoming suicidal,
inviting a life forever in the dream world.
It puts a dark spin on the material, but at
least he always gets his happy ending with
his family.
Inside Out
The death of Bing Bong was one of the most
heartbreaking moments in Pixar history, as
the lovable imaginary friend sacrificed himself
so Joy could get back to HQ.
But maybe things didn’t end that tragically.
A theory claims that Bing Bong ended up at
Foster’s Home for Imaginary Friends, the
famous Cartoon Network series.
It sounds like wishful thinking, but it adds
up.
Foster’s home is where imaginary friends
go when their kids outgrow them, and Bing
Bong’s unique design makes it easy for him
to fit in with the collection of eye-catching
creatures that live there.
We certainly prefer this to something so incredibly
sad.
Toy Story 2
In this Pixar sequel, Jessie breaks our hearts
when she sings about the great times she had
with her original owner, Emily.
Could that be Andy’s mom?
One theory seems to think so, pointing out
a strong connection between the cowboy hat
Andy wears in the first film and the one Emily
has in the second.
Though viewers never get a great look at Emily,
her appearance could resemble a younger version
of Andy’s mom, and we never learned her
last name.
Pixar’s no stranger to fan theories, and
this one takes the cake as the most emotional.
Jessie ended up back with Emily, even though
she never knew it.
Titanic
James Cameron is one of the most famous sci-fi
directors of all time, and he may have slipped
some of the genre into his Oscar winning period
piece.
There are some who believe Jack Dawson is
a time traveler who came on the ship to save
Rose from suicide.
During his time with Rose, Jack mentions a
man made lake that wasn’t created until
five years after the Titanic sank and promises
to take Rose on a roller coaster that wouldn’t
exist until 1916.
His hairstyle and backpack are also unfit
for the era, having been popularized in the
1930s.
Historical inaccuracies happen all the time
in Hollywood, but Cameron never could have
bet on this happening.
Ferris Bueller’s Day Off
One interpretation of the classic teen comedy
is that it’s a John Hughes version of Fight
Club.
Some fans think the whole film takes place
in Cameron’s head as he stays home from
school sick.
Cameron is a loner who doesn’t get along
with his father, so he creates an ultra-popular
friend to hang out with, and Ferris’ girlfriend
Sloane is based on a girl Cameron has a crush
on.
The film does dive into the fantastical with
all of the “SAVE FERRIS” movements, which
could be read as wish fulfillment on the part
of Cameron.
It’s also worth noting that Ferris leaves
Cameron once he decides to stand up against
his father, indicating he’s no longer needed.
Iron Man 2
At long last, Spider-Man can play in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
Peter Parker made his debut in Captain America:
Civil War, but did audiences meet him much
earlier?
One theory floating around suggests Peter
is the small kid wearing an Iron Man mask
at the Stark Expo in Queens, ready to take
on a robot.
Peter is revealed to be a fan of Stark’s,
so it makes sense he would want to attend
the event.
And since Parker is a high-schooler in the
MCU, the age lines up as well.
Obviously, Marvel couldn’t use Peter’s
name since they didn’t have the rights,
but it’s nice to think in retrospect this
is what happened.
Star Wars
It’s well documented that many Star Wars
fans hate Jar-Jar Binks.
But what if the Gungan was a sinister being?
Some feel that Jar-Jar is actually a Sith
Lord co-conspiring with Palpatine to rule
the galaxy.
Binks uses his outward appearance as a buffoon
as a ruse to mislead others, similar to Yoda
in The Empire Strikes Back.
The theory also suggests that Jar-Jar used
a mind trick on the Senate when he proposed
Palpatine receive emergency powers, leading
to the formation of the Empire.
There’s no denying it’s a fun concept,
but Disney isn’t going to touch Jar-Jar
with a 10 foot pole, so we’ll have no idea
if it’s true.
Conclusion
So what do you think of our list?
Do these theories change the way you view
popular films?
Which ones are your favorites?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more fun videos!